[Music]
hello, how are you, greet them, lighten millo
with your brief informative for today, Tuesday
, July 20, we start with a news story in
development since two children were
found dead inside a house
in henderson, the authorities
responded to a residence located
near san siro  and highway 95 at
around 6:30
p.m. agents called this
incident suspicious there are still no other
people in custody and no information is known
about the deceased
today clark county commissioners will
meet urgently to discuss
the increase in positive cases  of
coronavirus they will talk about a plan to
reduce infections in southern
nevada
this meeting will be at one in the afternoon
in the offices located in the downtown
you will be able to know all the details of
our page news now dotcom
diagonal in spanish registration for
the program  shake and start today this
offers before and
after school activities for students
Kindergarten through fifth grade for
pre-school activities
are seven dollars per day for
after school activities are ten dollars per
day there is a registration fee of
$20 per student for more
information on schools that
participate in this and all  the details
visit and start diagonal dotcom in
Spanish
and now we turn to the weather forecast
we will have a hot day reaching
104 degrees with some humidity for the
valley the temperatures will rise
tomorrow however the
chances of rain return as we approach the
weekend nice day  I'm
Salí Jaramillo and this was his brief
information on inclusion in Spanish
[Music]